foreign
[Laughter]
myself I see that dude standing there
you can put it behind me if you want in
a minute
[Laughter]
Tom's getting intimidated by evil
SpongeBob watching
what are you doing that you don't want
to watch Tom I'm doing a show man oh
okay
uh hi everybody it's Friday night
and it's the Sidetrack show Zach says
guess what guys I ran into someone who
watches the show on Resident Evil live
stream of all things and I told the dude
streaming uh the game who's kind of
popular about the show thank you very
much that's awesome so wait a minute you
told him about the show but he already
knew the show no no he's saying the guy
that was hosting the show didn't know
about the show but somebody else that
was that was in the chat I'm assuming
watch the show so today did they know
that you were the famous bathhouse
Zachary
bathhouse the famous bathhouse act who
does not have cooties with the tingling
TT
Tammy says no return Spock that's what I
said I'll put it back here in a bit you
better put him back I don't look up here
and I'm looking up here I like it
beautiful face this beautiful face and
then I see you sitting next to me
I knew that was coming
I know I know you so well because I was
I was even gonna interrupt and go oh and
then me you're a beautiful face and then
and then her ugly ass over there a spot
watching me Jenny's got the second
badass dress on right now
I was getting ready to throw down man
before the show started I was like the
show you're starting you're gonna
imagine we may have to do a little
stream on stream made out
you guys got to see this
this show yeah we gotta go we gotta go
we gotta go out yeah
it's just sexy man okay
you get it all
right before Becca I wore it before yeah
okay
boom
Zach says I like the anime girl hair
Jenny thank you I was actually gonna um
gonna tease my actual hair like because
we're going out like I said after show
it's momentum worry tonight
but then I thought to myself
man I always like how my hair looks like
all teased up and everything like that
but then like the next day I'm like
they're trying to comb all the knots out
going why why did I do it yeah and I
just take like big things out so I was
just like [__] I'm just clipping this
[__] in here that's how I'm gonna that's
how I'm Gonna Roll
ah
Zach said I forget who it was he said he
hasn't watched the show in a man okay
well you know
uh let me see I approve of the change in
Decor well that's good yeah we like I
said this those curtains and all and the
mirrors and the candles and stuff that's
been there the whole time y'all just
couldn't see it because change the
direction of the camera yeah we'd
basically just took the camera from like
it was over there and then we just moved
it over I like this much better Jen
doesn't though I think she likes all
these all these knickknacks behind it
well I like all my all my horror [__]
yeah I think that looks more like a show
though yeah but I'm just saying I like
all my horror [__] yeah that's why I
have it on the wall because I like
looking at it I like looking at it Zach
says good luck wearing that dress here
in the winter yeah well I mean it's
summer here but yeah but you could
actually wear this in the winter too
probably 95 of the time and you'd be
fine all you gotta do is wear a coat
over it not even not even but yeah I
kind of feel like it really only gets
cold enough to wear a coat maybe a
couple of days
yeah you know more like raincoats most
well most of the time winter in Florida
you could probably just get away with
like a little hoodie I mean I don't
think last year I don't think I wore I
think I wore a coat one day like when we
went out like uh I went out like an
actual coat rest of the time it's like I
would just wear my little
my little hoodie and that was uh plenty
see if they're saying see what Zach and
all everybody's saying about the about
the about the new uh camera angle yeah
yeah it looks less busy too easier to
focus on on you lot yeah and then
somebody says it's like a local horror
television channel that's that's right
it's yeah local you can still see my
little Toms River over there we um I see
him peeking and tearing each other up
and throw down behind us just behind us
on down this is this is a this is this
is a sex stage well yeah that's what
that's originally why we changed it
because we wanted that background for
streamate and then I was just like well
I don't want to have to move the [__]
camera back and forth every time we do
this show or every time we do streamate
so we're just gonna leave it here you
know what I mean
somebody thinks we like it so that's
good if we had to we could actually move
this table back a couple another inches
and
a few more inches of that one next to
you too
and um
get more space over here we got plenty
of space that's fine I'm not moving this
[__] around again
because that I can't move that because
it's got those huge bookshelves
we're not moving it I already moved this
yeah I can move it we already moved this
we're not we're not moving everything
around again okay we did that last
weekend and I'm over it I don't like
moving [__] around all the time
um how long did those curtains take to
set up because God that's some
complicated bunching
um honestly not that much I just put up
the um the rods I put those up like
right when we moved in
pretty much like the the week after we
moved in and I didn't really have to do
much to them like I said they came on I
got them on Amazon and they were not
they were very very inexpensive I was
actually surprised for how fancy they
look I think they were only
I want to say they were eighteen dollars
each
that sounds about right those curtains
okay which is like not bad
considering how nice they look yeah and
I've had them a couple of years I'm sure
they're not super high quality but they
look cool and that's all I care about
right actually
oh that's right this is now up here yeah
we don't have it's not attached to the
what you call it anymore
Paul Flint said need more bookshelves
too my place is a library yeah I got
um two big huge like Ikea type
bookshelves over there and then I have a
little half one over there and they're
all completely packed like not even like
just all the way across and then there's
books on top of those books and now I
have a big pile of books on top of the
[__] that I don't have any room for so
I'm definitely going to be looking into
getting new bookshelves and like a no
I'm not gonna say like a dumbass but
like a glutton for punishment let's say
that
um when we were at Books A Million last
weekend the coffee lady talked me into
getting
a membership again
because we are in there a lot we'd buy a
lot of coffee in there I do buy a lot of
books in there like to review for the
show and [__] like that so I was like
it's not that expensive I think it's
only what was it it's 25 for a year yeah
and I got like a [__] ton of coupons
like so I was just like yeah it seems
worth it because we all we go there
pretty much every weekend and we got a
new cat
yeah in case you guys were not here
because like I said we streamed
um on Monday we did a review of the meg2
but
um apparently the [__] at Warner
Brothers decided that we had infringed
on their copyright by simply talking
about the movie
um and so YouTube Took the video down
so and I don't know if it's going to be
reinstated I already like bitched about
it but we'll see if that gets resolved
and I wasn't like I said I wasn't so
much mad at the review going away
because I was like you know that's not
that big of a deal but I was mad because
we told everybody on that show about
like adopting a new cat and now we have
to like repeat it all the time in case
anybody hasn't heard about it so you
know what I mean
that's I don't know
Paul Flint says got six very large ones
too yeah I definitely probably need two
get more
get more because I also have I have like
a little shelf here that has some books
piled on it and old magazines and stuff
like taboo and weird tales and I got a
bunch of vinyl records which I can't
play because I don't have a record
player anymore but I still have vinyl
records because I can't get rid of them
because they're awesome
but yeah we don't really know if we have
the lights set up right too if we look
too bright just tell us I can
probably turn these lights down a little
bit
exactly we look a little bit washed out
well I told you that before the thing
started but you said you said it looked
okay no I don't I don't [__] with those
that's your job
and it's like I didn't really change
that and that's like on a lower setting
yeah
I know but we've used this before yeah
that camera might be a little more light
Paul Flynn said not bright okay
yeah I didn't think it was too bad back
up
okay
didn't make a difference
I don't know
uh Zach says well Viacom owns Warners
yeah that's right uh so I'm not shocked
it got struck down because they will
copyright anything seemingly yeah but
the weird thing about the whole thing
and I said this in my complaint
was that we gave it a good review well
no that wasn't what I was gonna say I
was gonna say that um there were like I
watched at least five other reviews of
that movie that used
Stills or the trailer or something like
that like in the review and those are
still there so I don't really understand
why they picked on ours because I didn't
even use the trailer any stills from the
[__] or anything just talked about it we
just talked about it and then we went on
and talked about other things and I was
just like are you guys High what the
[__] I think they're just doing like
ai's doing that [__] if anybody so much
has mentions there with me they're gonna
[__] yeah because they're afraid of
people affecting the opening
thank you very much Jeffy art what'd he
say love the new look a quick shout
about uh Gerard Shaffer working in
Wilton Manors oh yeah that's right you
sent me a uh you commented about this my
current stomping grounds and a huge
lgbtq Community plenty of bath houses or
private clubs LOL yeah I've never
actually been there I've only you would
think I've lived in Florida pretty much
all my life but I've only been to South
Florida like two times and I've never
been to Wilton Manors actually who's
this who's the SIM card to
the guy with the serial killer guy we
talked about on okay because he was a
cop he was down there in Wilton Manors I
don't think it was
um you know it obviously wasn't uh
wasn't full of bath houses back then I
don't think because that was like that
was like the late seven like late 60s or
early 70s but
I wish straight people had bath houses
the girls maybe they do the girls
wouldn't show up well yeah it would just
be a bunch of dudes the perfect dudes
with with baggy screws yeah standing
around looking at each other where are
the ladies at where all the women at
yeah we don't go to we don't go to
places
[Laughter]
it's
a dude thing
so you'll go to Secrets but they go with
their boyfriends
yeah that's more like a swingers thing
so that's more like couples yeah like
you know what I mean
but uh yeah so then uh
when I was saying about the cats Paulson
said love cats yeah we do too we have
three of them now so yeah and um
I don't think uh I don't think Vegas is
feeling good she's vomiting a lot and at
the vet said she was uh
had kidney problems she's had kidney
problems
yeah I don't know she seems happy but
she's just she's drinking water
yeah but she's not eating very much the
past week
yeah she doesn't seem to be acting like
she's sick or anything but she's kind of
yeah she's laying off the food
last time at took her a little while her
kidneys came back and then
um then she got better for a while yeah
and you know
that vet said that um if they get a lot
of damn vaccines is that it tends to be
rough on their kidneys that might have
been that
[__] um they had some vaccines came
out when they were when she was a little
kitten that was kind of known for that
he I don't know if she got that one
though
it's just you know no Talent
uh Zach says uh he says The Boathouse I
guess you mean the bath house the
bathroom The Boat House you go to uh is
pretty cool but you feel like you'll get
murdered going into the steam bath it's
dark and what is a bull house or a bath
house a bath house okay I know because
he typed Boathouse because I'm assuming
that the spell check okay yeah that's
why I was making you do it they don't
want you talking about bad thousand
well no I just think that some like bath
house isn't it's a word but it's not
like a it's not as common a word as
Boathouse so it's going to jump to
Boathouse probably John Smith said in
economic terms dick is always selling at
a low price yeah
it's true it's called dick flation dick
flation yeah except not because no yes
the dicks are inflating they're
deflating but I guess that could also be
diffusion dick deflation yeah dick
deflation yeah yeah there's too many of
them
too many of them in the market just
dicks everywhere it's just a huge Forest
of dicks everywhere you go all that damn
hyper give me kicking 75 of them out
yeah
um
Paul says hope your cat gets well soon
thank you very much she's like I said
she's doing good she does have little
little kidney problems like every now
and then but
she usually goes to the vet and then
like she's all right again after a
little while
but yeah our other cats she's
14 13.
yeah 13 or 14. 14.
so yeah so she's our older one and then
we have two other ones
um you know for people that are new we
have Pookie and she's she's six and then
just this past weekend we got another we
adopted another cat her name is Dakota
yeah that's what the name was so she
came from the shelter and I was like
yeah she kind of looks like a Dakota so
we'll just go she's another manx yeah we
were excited because we don't usually
you don't usually see manx cats because
Pookie is a Manx and we've been talking
about getting another one like you know
so they could be buddies
and um we just always liked Pookie's
personality and like Mex cats are known
for like having that kind of real
interactive like almost puppy-like kind
of personality so we were kind of
thinking that we would get another one
but you don't usually see them like up
for adoption but we just happen to go in
PetSmart and there was one there and
they were like yeah she just came in
this morning from
um hofmeyer animal rescue
and she's still she's fairly young she's
14 months and she's pretty small here
she is oh like oh Tom got her yeah she
is
there she is
yeah she's split yeah she's pretty
little she looks like a little tiger
yeah do you want to be on the show she
got a tail okay she does kinda you want
to be on a shell she was like not
particularly
she's not into lap stuff
she likes us but she's not really yeah
she's real like affectionate though
she's from a shelter yeah
and uh she does funny stuff like
put her in the Box to bring her home and
she didn't make a peep didn't cry or
anything on the way home
just opened it up she came up like that
Pookie sorry went oh
she jumped out and immediately just
walked around the house and was going
yeah this is cool it's just my house now
okay yeah and she stays just on top step
she's stayed there for about a day yeah
and then she sleeps a lot walks around
she she's impressed about how much food
there is
she likes the food because she's been
their feeder you know bare minimum
probably
at uh shelters yeah because they have a
lot of cats to feed you know so they're
not gonna like overstuff them yeah
but oh surely she'll get fat here let's
see her and they don't know what to make
of her
Pookie's warmed up to her
um but she just ignores the other cats
because she's used to cats
yeah she was like not hostile she was
just kind of like she looked at pookie
was like oh yeah it's not okay all right
yeah yeah she's like yeah she just kind
of yawned and was like yawned and rolled
over
huh
[Laughter]
what's going on
you're sleeping I got videos of Pokey
creeping up and creeping up and looking
at Dakota on the on the steps just
freaking out that that cat's asleep
yeah believe it the cat's asleep it's
sleeping right in front of me he's not
even scared you know what I mean
poor Pookie yeah and then Pookie go back
underneath the bed and hide but she's
Pookie's uh made peace with it now she
realizes that this cat doesn't do
anything yeah that it's not gonna like
it's not a threat to her yeah it doesn't
even make any noise
no not really the first night we brought
her home she was kind of like she wasn't
crying but she was like meowing a lot
like in the middle of the night and kept
waking me up she calling her friends I'm
guessing yeah but it's like she hasn't
really done that since then yeah but
that's I mean I felt so bad because I
wasn't actually sure how pookie was
going to react to us bringing another
cat home
because you know she's been around
Beijing but Beijing was grown when we
got Pookie when pookie was a little baby
so she's never experienced
having another cat be brought in like
while when she was grown so
I I didn't expect her to be that she
wasn't mean she was terrified yeah like
she having the cat she's like what the
[__] she'd run from her and then she
just she just kind of scrunched down and
like ran under the bed and she was under
the bed for like a day and a half like
she wouldn't come out
it doesn't matter but yeah now she she
but she was interested she kept like she
she'd come out from under the bed and
like look at the kitty like in the hall
and kind of creep and be like what is
that kitty doing yeah and then like the
kitty would do it would move or
something she'd be like [__] like she'd
run back into the bag
balls grooming
pookie was just mystified like ah she
does the same thing I do
what is this
why is it sitting where I sit because it
it took all her spots I know I know I
felt so bad it took all her family it
was almost like she knew where all the
best spots were like she came in and
she's like she immediately took over
like Pookie's little post at the top of
the stairs yeah I gotta think her
favorite little lounge chair downstairs
by the front door she said and I was
like oh pokey's gonna be so mad
but she seems still got nervous she
doesn't care last night she was eating
out of Pookie's dish and pookie was just
sitting there watching like okay all
right no big deal then I gave her a meat
gave her a meat stick and then she chew
on that meat stick and watch the other
cat eat out of her dish and she didn't
care okay so she's like I mean Pookie is
not I have never seen her
mad about anything like she's not
hostile toward other cats she did hiss
at that cat but because she was afraid
she wasn't trying to fight or nothing
like that
but she's real
chill you know what I mean she's not
hostile it's worth other cats generally
actually as a matter of fact when we
first got her Beijing was kind of I
don't know if I'd go as far as saying
hostile but Beijing was like what is
this little kitten that's come here and
like is trying to usurp my position in
the house and she would like Kiss It
Pookie and stuff like that and pookie
was just like this tiny little kitten
and she was just like I just want to
play yeah and then Beijing was like [__]
off little one you know she was like
that Boogie just fought back though she
didn't care yeah she was just like hey
yay
yeah she would just attack
Chase Beijing
she's just incorrigible
she's a very dominant personality but
this cat's chilling her out yeah I think
this cat chills are out alive hey what's
up we're talking about you hi Pokey oh
your Pokey come in where is she she's
looking for the other gap she was just
in here Pokemon yeah
Paul says should do a cat live stream
I mean you know I I've thought about it
yeah Allison said Jenny you guys will
spoil her rotten yeah we will cookie is
already spoiled rotten
this this one so far isn't very
interactive she does her own thing all
day she'll look out windows and she's
happy but she's just she's a shelter cat
so she doesn't really need a lot of
attention
she does seem to like attention she
likes like if you she doesn't come to
you to seek it out right whereas Pookie
does Pookie is just kind of like hey
love me
or She'll follow you around everywhere
this this um Dakota does kind of follow
you around a little bit and like I said
the first day we brought her home I sat
down with she came in and she was like
hey what's going on and I was like and I
sat and she was like looking all around
like oh this is nice like all this house
and everything and I sat down on the
floor next to her and she immediately
was just kind of like rubbing her head
all over and like licking my hands and
she would be like rolled over and showed
me her belly and all this other stuff so
I was just kind of like okay I guess
she's all right so she was like
immediately comfortable
so we got a pretty good crowd in there
yeah yeah so if you guys have any uh
questions or if you want to talk about
anything he's going to drop it in the
comments section
and um we can go in that direction we're
just getting everybody ready for the
weekend being Friday and everything
and uh we got to go out
in case you're just joining us now me
and Jen got to go out to the club
tonight
and um
a little swell is going to be there
oh that's good yeah he's gonna be there
I'm gonna try to save him I haven't seen
him in a while yeah and then uh
I just got to keep from
drinking too much because I gotta drive
there yeah
yeah and I'll be drinking when I get
there and then I come back
just gotta be careful yeah
put some more ice in this how you doing
the price all right well you know it
melts quick all right here's how that
happens Oracle says spoiled rotten is
the level of attention one should give a
cat I agree I agree
that's why I kind of
oh I was so conflicted because it's like
we have been talking about getting
another cap for a long time because I
said I think Pookie needs a buddy you
know what I mean because she likes to
play and she's real interactive and
stuff like that I said she needs another
kitty to hang out with so she's not
lonely like if we're not home and stuff
like that
um because you know Beijing is just kind
of like nope I'm too old for this [__]
you know beijing's like I just want to
lay on the back of the couch leave me
alone so um so we have been talking
about it for a long time but then when
we saw
that cat when we saw Dakota on Monday
when we were at the mall
I got PetSmart and I was just kind of
like oh man it's like I really want that
cat she seems really sweet and
everything like that but I was like how
is Pookie gonna react and I was like
really stressing out about it but and I
was stressing about it the whole time
because like I said for a couple of days
she was like just head under the bed and
she wouldn't come out and I was just
kind of like oh man
this is bad but she seems to have gotten
over it so
hopefully they'll hang out
um
let's see Oracle says I have some good
some news to share some good and some
bad uh good news my husband had to have
a lump removed from his arm but the
biopsy is expected to be benign that's
good
um and then cute news my niece turned
six months old on Tuesday oh
oh somebody like Zach reminded me um
William friedkin died who's that the guy
that directed The Exorcist oh okay you
know
Oracle says crappy news my contract is
expiring end of September well [__]
hopefully I mean are you do you think
you're gonna be able to find anything
else or
I don't know I'm kind of thinking about
um
putting in my notice at my job
and then working out the rest of the
month and then
go into streaming full-time
you know
it's more our style
it's definitely more our style we just
jump on in 45 minutes make like 60 bucks
well I figured it out I said to make the
same amount of money that I make at my
job
I was like we need
48 minutes of of paid time at our at our
at the rate we're at now
now sometimes it might take you six
hours to get that 48 minutes of paid
time because a lot of times you're just
kind of sitting around waiting for
people to come in and pay you to do
something
but once I figured that out
mathematically I'm like that really
doesn't sound like all that much
like you you do 48 paid minutes that's
like 100 something dollars yeah and you
know that's and we were actually
um uh we have on that the last time we
streamed we average better than that
because we had more than one person
watch it
yeah at one time there was one time when
there were five guys in there paying at
once
yeah that's how that's how we got that
amount of money into a short period of
time
yeah because we were really only on for
like an hour and 15 minutes and made
like 40. we made all that money in 45
minutes and then we stayed on for
another half hour or so yeah it started
to sputter out the traffic started to
die because
I guess you could say the morning shift
the afternoon kind of shift was leading
that's well that's not really a good way
to put it it does seem to be better in
like the morning like mid-morning than
at night
uh British customers in there yeah
because they're five hours ahead of us
right we had a British client he was
pretty cool
I know like I said he was so nice and
polite yeah he turned his camera on we
didn't see him he was just
he said where are you in the United
States of Florida he goes oh yeah I'm in
London
I said oh great yeah what are you doing
he's mad I'm horny as hell yeah I'm at
the office
I was like all right all right so
nothing in particular there no not in
particular just you know so it just do
what you want yeah so we just put on a
good show and like
nobody jumped in on that one it was
later when we were doing the BDSM shows
when they jumped in yeah yeah we had
like five people yeah a guy asked me to
rough her up [__] I was roughing her up
and then the guy started jumping in on
that like this zapper you know
but you know we actually do it but it's
we're using I'm using stage techniques
and [__] you know
and camera angles and cup in your hand
and
trying to make a slap sound a lot a lot
louder than it actually is and she's
good she knows when it's coming she it's
like pro wrestling you know yeah it's
gonna hit me with a chair with a folding
chair
that would be funny
you should do that we should do we
should do like a wrestling stream one
I can't look how red she is look how
rich
that's okay though
yeah Aaron says what is this thing
you're doing I keep missing is it like a
fans only type thing
um it's called well I guess like only
someone streaming yeah it's um it's
called streamate it's not the only
platform that you can do this on there's
other ones uh yeah there's I think the
most famous one's probably Chatterbait
yeah live Jasmine they're live jobs Man
live Jasmine yeah but we like stream
eight so far yeah streaming is the best
one because Jasmine is kind of like
stream mate too it's a similar system
but that's a token site
yeah well the reason I like streamate is
because it doesn't work the same as
ChatterBait and stuff like that where
there's all these kind of weird rules
when you're doing online
sex work I guess what you know you're
you're doing essentially like live porn
free you know you're in your own house
and but you people are just like asking
like paying you to do certain things
yeah they're gonna come up with a scene
and pay you to do the [__] seat right
right basically so you just do that
uh you know live for them and and this
is gonna here's the thing though
this is not a full-on scene me and Jen
have done those we got them for sale all
right
chances are a student's gonna last five
minutes
so it's
it's it's it's fake basically you're
doing it but it's not for you it's for
the customer yeah you know
he's he's custom-made live porn
interactive yeah that's what it is and
like I said some people are really
specific in what they want and some
people are just kind of like ah whatever
like they just like anything it made no
mistake porn's kind of fake too well
yeah you know it's a it's totally set up
it's a setup even if it looks real
amateur and it looks like man we're
sneaking off and doing this or man she
you know here she is I took she didn't
know that I videotaped her or you know
this is my wife's this is my friend's
wife
there's paperwork involved you can't
just post anything you got to have
[__] uh they're very stringent it's
stringent they gotta know who everybody
is in the video how old they are
and they have to sign release forms and
consent forms yeah so there's no such
thing as like
well anything that doesn't have the they
do exist what we're talking about
real pirate [__] just something somebody
did on the phone on a Wham and trying to
post it that won't be up there for long
they'll take it down because there any
there isn't any paperwork behind it yeah
you can't really verify who those people
are how old they are or if they
consented to have that
film there's some girl she's just drunk
and rolling around and guys are taking
advantage of her and uh they're acting
like they're really getting away with
something if it's on that site it's
consent forms for side
yeah we had to do yeah we do stream mate
stream mate we had to go through a big
long process where we each had to take
multiple pictures of our face so they
could 3D map them then you have to take
pictures of your ID you have to take a
pictures of you with your ID and you
have to scan the ID the front and the
back
um you have to do all that stuff and
then they have to like vet you
and then and then before every single
time before we stream like as soon as
you hit stream now like start the show
they are like okay we have to start the
scan and you have to stick both your
faces in the [__] camera and they
have to 3D scan your face to make sure
that there's nobody that's not supposed
to be in there yeah because I only have
two people on my account me and him yeah
so if we you can bring in other people
but they have to go through all of the
rigmarole and we also sell videos on
many vids and that I had to I got an
account I had to do all that I you have
to take a picture of yourself with your
ID and a sign that says many vids and
the date and your name and all of a
sudden you have to like talk on it and
say the date is blah blah you have to do
all this legal [__] and then to put him
to put up videos that had him in them he
had to sign this big long legal consent
form
saying that you know I was allowed to
upload stuff like with him in it like in
perpetuity you know what I mean so I had
to do that too there's you know there's
all kinds of [__] that uh some of these
girls are doing some of these girls that
are doing kind
there's no like online consent forms
where you can get all that information
from somebody on the spot
s both sides of their ID their face and
then they [__]
they sign the consent form on her tablet
all right and then they even have a new
way where she can swab that dude's mouth
and run it through a [__] basically a
STD test in a matter a matter of like 15
minutes there's like a pretty accurate
STD test with just a
chemicals you shake on this thing
they're using that now
that way you know if she has a quick
encounter with some dude she's let's
record this that's what they're doing
you know at a concert or out in public
or something and she was just they got
girls that are just meeting these guys
be on camera with me usually it's a fan
yeah someone who knows her
I recognize you just okay I want to do
something real quick Let's help me make
some money here I'll get here's 50. you
know so she hires him to start with her
because there has to be there really
should be some kind of a
there's got to be some kind of contract
there's got to be consensus yeah there's
got to be all that kind of stuff and
then it's better if there's some kind of
money in exchange to where she can now
say that he's a Hired Hand that he was a
hired performer which kind of gives her
some more cover in different ways you
know I mean that I think you can even
use it as a tax write-off
yeah you can but like I said doing any
kind of sex work like this you got to be
real careful because I don't like that
word sex works that means sounds like
we're hooking yeah well it's I mean
that's just like a general term but you
know what I mean it's good too general
what I was gonna say was that you have
to be really careful because a lot of um
one thing I noticed was streaming is
that a lot of your mainstream uh you
know pay platforms like PayPal or cash
app or anything like that will not uh
work with adult
entertainment sites even ones that have
been vetted and that are reputable and
stuff like that so there have sprung up
like a little side business I guess in
other pay platforms that are friendly to
that sort of thing
um the problem is that they usually
charge fees yeah so when I get paid
through streamate I usually just have
them send me a check yeah it means like
going old school and then I just like
put it in my so I get a check from them
every Wednesday like depending
you know
Paul Flynn said you've been looking at
my internet history
[Laughter]
channel is called Jen Tom cam one word
and that's us on there yeah so you can
you can follow us there whenever we go
live you'll get notified yeah we might
we'll probably there's videos on sale on
there but it's only videos of Jim yeah I
had to be edited out of a lot of them
because
for some crazy reason whoever owns the
account whoever owns the account on
stream mate only they can post videos of
themselves it doesn't make any [__]
sense but for some reason
I can stream with her and do and and
perform we can even record the
performance evidently from what I
understand on that platform and sell it
on that platform but not anything we
recorded off of that platform it doesn't
make any sense they said they're going
to try to change that yeah they said
they are working on it like this
but yeah well we determined that it's
probably because I think there's a
difference between streaming and
recording communication so and then it's
probably supporting different legal
distribution of pornography which might
be a different
laws involved with that they may not be
licensed for that yet
but the thing is is that if you're doing
something live what we're doing is
basically live stripping
online so kind of like on that level so
that's not quite live that's not like
distribution of pornography that's more
like just a communication right in other
words like a telephone call it's like
that a video call
there it is it's not to the masses it's
also Street nothing and streammates in
public
now some people do stuff in public yeah
you're technically you're technically
you're not supposed to yeah Colombia
does that and some girls really push the
limits of what you can do in public
um you're not supposed to be showing
anything below the bill
in public on there but it's best not to
do anything public
no no free shows make them pay that's
what I mean it's like the whole reason
for us being on there is like oh yeah
it's fun but it's like you know is to
make money so if you're like giving
everything away for free yeah no one's
gonna pay for [__] you know what I mean
so in streammate we're just hanging out
in the set talking people are coming in
and out if they start talking with to us
and they have a choice of either
gone private or gone exclusive if they
go private and pay a certain amount of
minute but other people can join the
show and interact so we get paid for
everybody who joins that's that's how
that one thing happened
they go exclusive it's only him nobody
else can come in
but in exclusive he can turn his camera
on free of charge that's how we got set
up yeah and uh and it's about half the
guys that go exclusive do turn the
camera on cam two cams yeah and you'd be
surprised on what these dudes look like
one dude
was ifbb men's fitness quality level guy
I mean he was [__] shredded
and they could be doing porn
I would say a lot of the dudes that
showed
probably all the guys that actually uh
turned their cameras could have could
could be doing porn
just straight porn standards for the
males are not that high yeah so you know
the gay horse Tenors a lot higher yeah
they are but uh some of them were like
that but that one guy was very fit
and then that Viking dude
he could have easily made it in porn
oh yeah so we have one guy Viking
something or other and he was bragging
that he had a [__] 10 and a half inch
dick 11 inch 11 and it's a dick he was
saying that in public and [__] there's
other people around in that in the chat
room that says yeah [__] you're
gonna have to [__] go exclusive turn
the camera on [__] prove that you
just can't [__] come in here and say
that he did
when it's supposed to turn the camera on
it for sure enough that [__] was
huge it's a good Shake Too airplane look
like you had a big old beard like a
viking he's probably about six three
probably by looking at him real [__]
real [__] stocky
and [__] was yeah probably about
11 inches
like big around it's a [__] beer can
John Smith said both the funniest and
most disturbing genre amateur [__] stuff
you would be surprised how many people
ask for yeah they asked stuff yeah yeah
I don't know exactly what they want us
to do though
see that's what I mean I always just
kind of feel like because a lot of
people do ask for that
um
you have to see some of the videos so
you got to do your homework on that well
no but it's like we've done it a couple
of times yeah it's just that
you're not really sure if they want to
cuck you out or if you want to cut them
out or no they want them they're the
cooks right but you you don't insult
them enough you didn't give them what
they wanted
not really insult them but you didn't
[__] you got to talk to them
constantly during all that
well kind of hard to do because you were
like knocking me over so yeah
um let's see junkyard said I wonder what
only fans stance is on fetish imagery
that doesn't necessarily Show faces
do you think that's a workaround even
creating erotic AI art might start
becoming an industry I wouldn't [__]
with only fans we tried to mess with it
and just it's damn near impossible to
get on only fans
yeah if you want to go on fansley
family will take you it's easy to get on
did you ever get accepted no how come I
got accepted I don't know
I mean it took a while for you to get
accepted too I think they get a lot of
people I don't know yeah but I didn't I
didn't notice we gotta go back and check
on that and see what the deal was well I
check my email every day so it's I would
have seen it okay
um
let me see Paul Flynn says not got laid
in years
Zach says gay porn is also better porn
fight me
where I actually quite like acorn
well yeah it's it's shot differently
it doesn't matter who the guy is in
straight porn because the attention
isn't on him and he's just it's just a
damn dick
and all the all the cameras just
focusing just on that on the girl or
girls if there's more than one of them
in high-end
Factory gay porn the guys are the stars
they're just they're just totally in the
camera the whole time
a lot of face shots and [__]
it's shot better I would say yeah but
that's not what guys want to see that's
not what straight guys want to see well
you're right it's like everything
right it's tailored to the to the viewer
what the demographics of the view are
viewer is
but um
good
pretty much anybody can be a
straight porn star as long as you can
stay hard
yeah I mean there's really not much
better for entry honestly like even
stuff like you know on streammate and
things like that it's like you would be
um I mean there's really all types on
there there's all ages and all sizes and
all everything yeah they're all good
business and they're all getting
business so it's like that kind of makes
me feel better in a way well it's
different angles you'll see couples in
there that are
very overweight in their 50s or 60s and
you just said why the [__] is anybody
doing them when you've got all these
[__] hotties all in the windows next
to them some people want to get busy
with people who look just like them
that's what that is
they're not comfortable around real good
looking people they want to be around
something looks like that
it's a more personal connection I guess
well and maybe it seems more like you're
watching something illicit because like
I feel like if you're watching like
mainstream produce porn like you know
everybody's hot and good looking and
it's like yeah but most people don't
really look like that in real life so
you feel like you're watching something
you shouldn't be watching you know what
I mean maybe that's what it is according
to Bill it's but people like some people
like to see people who look just like
them
that's what he said
you know Bill's been doing this for a
long time he says if you have people who
are just unattractive they still sell
but they sell to unattractive people
they they like the people that look like
them hey unattractive people have money
too yeah Jeffy art said A friend of mine
uses just for fans and he told me that
it's crucial to set up solid boundaries
when it comes to engaging the audience
keep it polite and friendly but know
that dirty talk is money yeah yeah well
yeah that's because we've like yeah we
figured out that a lot of people will
come in and try to get you to say dirty
[__] to them yeah yeah so they don't
have to pay for anything yeah
like because some of the some people I
guess that's all it takes they just want
somebody to like say some so they'll
come in and like ask certain questions
and stuff like that in general the worst
in the adult industry are only fans
girls they're like the least
professional
um
their skin is the thinnest
and they're the kind where if they think
you're talking dirty to them they'll
block you uh they'll get rid of the
people they'll get rid of their own
customers they'll find out that one of
their customers is married so she'll
block him just they just do stupid [__]
because
the average woman is just not cut out
for this kind of work they take it too
personally they don't really know what
especially if they're young they don't
know what men are or how men actually
work and they think there's some kind of
a morality behind what they're doing
no this is entertainment you're selling
fantasy
and yeah that dude's married but you may
be keeping him from cheating
if he didn't have some kind of a [__]
vent or an outlet that dude probably
would be getting hookers
okay so yeah you're you're your your
DM's gonna be filled with married guys
with kids and [__] with daughters the
same age as you okay God doesn't
differentiate that way you know he just
sees you as a woman he doesn't see you
as somebody the same age as his daughter
or whatever he just guys don't really
work that way you're just trying to do a
sexual transaction and it's just visual
so
if you can't handle that if a woman's
not mature enough for that she doesn't
need to be in this kind of work and a
lot of them don't make it uh
the average girl in in uh according to
what bill says the average girl in the
video industry was what he he does is
like four months
they can't take it
because women aren't built for that
they're not built for gang bangs they're
not built for this [__] you know you
gotta have
hahaha
you gotta have a sense of humor you got
to have a
you got you gotta almost be like a
Kearney in a certain way that this is
all just a scab we're trying to get
money out of the customer we're gonna do
this and that none of this is real this
is all theater you know and you have to
approach it the same way you would
approach an acting job yes like acting
because right it's the same thing yeah
and then she's got to be tough enough to
realize yeah all these dicks are gonna
be coming out and all this [__] and I'm
gonna swallow this and that
that's not really who you are that was
just that one job but everybody's going
to treat you a certain way after that
they're not going to look at you
it's really good it's really going to
affect your relationships
it's not healthy for a young person
unless they're
just gifted with a certain [__] kind
of mind you know well like I said some
people really really like doing that
yeah and other ones are just they're
doing it for the money for the money
yeah but the problem is is that it's not
worth the money how the toll that it's
going to take on you on your uh if
you're young the tall it's going to take
on your relationships is not really not
worth what they're paying you
um
there has to be more to it you have to
you have to enjoy it in a certain way
you have to enjoy that lifestyle
and that business and that type of
theater
but I would never recommend any of this
[__] for a young woman
uh one that hasn't been married or
hasn't had any kids or
because that can really get in the way
or something like that
plus over 30 Divorced with kids already
yeah you're in a different
Arena you know what I mean and you're
gonna be dealing with you're gonna be
dating with guys who are older more
mature to begin with and uh
grown women might be more mentally
solid you know they have their character
is more fixed
to where they can handle it
but young women can't handle it if you
ask me
well I don't you know to me like I said
it's not like you know we've talked
about this before it's not like I'm
going out escorting or going to a porn
shoot or anything like that like I said
we're just in the room like it's just me
and him it just means anything mean
anything
to do it's [__] we already do anyway
that's what I'm saying so it's just like
it's not that weird it's like oh there's
people on the other side of the that's
not what I'm on the screen like watching
us so it's like I'm not really that but
that doesn't take it really that that's
not what I was talking about though what
I was talking about was young
girls in porn especially yeah I actually
Studio porn
they're gonna have a bunch of they're
gonna have to [__] they work them to
death man you know
they're gonna try to get several hundred
scenes out of my year
you know and then they're gonna have to
go on tour and
go to dance clubs and then their their
sugar in and they're escorting too
usually
it's just because they
there's management studios are involved
they're like no you must do this for
your career oh you're gonna have to do
this they're making money off of her
she's making money too but they're
they'll tell them you only have a small
window where you can make this money you
know 10 years from now all this is going
to dry up you'll be lucky to last five
years make your money now so you just
try to [__] Ram them through the
system
and it breaks them yeah it's me well
because bill says he'd never do it I see
what he does you can see what his wife
does he says I would never really want
my wife to be a studio actress
no he's well they're Pro-Am and the
thing about it is that they know that
there's countless other women behind
them so it's like oh if you don't want
to do something somebody else wants
somebody else well and they're just
going to get everything that can get out
of you and then just like go on to the
next one that old school Studio system
is dehumanizing on a woman it's not
right
but I understand it's a machine though
yeah they're just trying to make money
it's just trying to make money and
they've willingly thrown themselves into
that machine
I wouldn't do it I really wouldn't
recommend it if you want to do something
like that man have your own accounts and
your own platforms and stream and make
your own material and then when you when
you have your [__] up on Mini vids and
you're getting residuals off of
everything and then you can just do what
you want to do right you do what you
want to do right and you don't have to
do anything you don't want to do like
with a bunch of strangers right
usually they're making content with
other content creators that have long
histories right you can see all their
videos that they made and there's a
little Social Scene you know oh yeah
yeah I heard about you yeah they collab
with each other and stuff like that but
it's like they don't have to it's not
like they show up to work and they're
like you have to do this or we're gonna
get somebody else right yeah you control
it you do whatever you want and that's a
lot more artistic
and it's more tailored you know a woman
can tailor her own material and her own
image and she has a lot more control
over yeah which is always much better
it's a lot better
and you don't have to do anything that
you don't want to do like I still would
not recommend okay young women nude
stuff solo acts and [__] like that
maybe with you and your girlfriend okay
fine that's not going to really get in
the way of
wife and kids and a future most guys
will tolerate that they'll be oh yeah
it's sexy you were out there doing it
because [__] I was young I was date
strippers I thought that [__] was hot as
[__]
oh the guy's paying to see him and I'm
[__] knocking it down you know I just
thought that was good I thought that was
really cool
a lot of these creators are like that
level so if you're in your 20s as long
as you're not
doing anything super outrageous you're
doing mostly solo stuff or maybe you and
your girlfriend [__] do a scene or
something most guys will tolerate that
but
oh [__] man dude these
these like oh they're gonna turn their
nose up at you
they might hit but they're not gonna
marry you you [__] crazy
Jeffy art says when you work in the
adult industry I'd imagine you need to
get into a headspace by reminding
yourself that you offer a service and
nothing else yeah partly yeah when we're
streaming it's like that kind of yeah
that's kind of how like I said it's kind
of a like a different situation when
you're doing what we're doing because
we're just like in here and we're just
it's just me and him so it's not like
these people are watching us but they're
not here you know what I mean they're
far away they're like in another country
or something they'll interact a little
bit yeah
but it's like
um
it is but the thing about it is that it
is fun like we do have a fun time doing
it like we'll have drinks we have music
on uh you know we're just kind of like
we're joking around and [__] like that
so it's good to have like a little bit
of a party atmosphere that gets like
more people to come in and yeah and see
what you're up to
but
um but yeah it is it is helpful to think
to yourself you're just like helping
these dudes
I mean pretty much keep them out of
trouble nothing wrong with that
everybody does it so you know these guys
are just are paying you to look at you
yep to help them out so let's you know
I'm not I'm not mad about it
not mad about it yeah and um
the thing is though is like
porn
I don't think it should be banned or
anything it shouldn't be controlled but
people have to start to yet start
educating these younger guys what the
effects are of that is that gonna really
[__] up your
endorphin systems and you know and can
you want to stay away from it as much as
possible you know because it'll
with especially if you're a young guy
and you're trying to develop [__]
skills and mate and [__] good
girlfriends and [__] that might get in
the way because it kind of warps your
perception more of your perception and
your expectations another thing was is
that you just it'll sap away your drive
to go out and find girlfriends or to
even care about them
so then you're going to have these women
going where are all the guys well
they're all jacking off they don't need
you they're all at home
and then you miss out on relationships
see because sex is only one part of it
man the relationship's really that's
good that's the best part
you know and
you can knock down a woman have a good
time but if you don't re if you don't
really know who she is you don't really
plan on ever having a relationship it's
not the same it's not the same but if
you know or you're friends with her that
it's a lot better
you know especially if the relationship
starts happening
so guys have to porn can affect a man's
game the young man's game you know
you want to understand that that's not
reality
although there are people that are that
good at bad
well sure yeah
but
you're not gonna deal with that lighting
and that camera angle although we have
those outfits we wear those
so yeah I have to back up go yeah if sex
is like that because most of the time
but I was dealing with goth girls you
know yeah and golf girls are good in bed
and they care about the way things look
and um
um when you're in your 20s and 30s man
[__] especially in your 20s sex is a
big deal so everybody puts uh puts
everything into it you know
and uh you're doing it in within the the
boundaries of a subculture you know
burning incense and [__]
canopy beds and Mazzy Star going and
yeah it's a whole situation yeah
drinking [__] box wine
[Laughter]
box Merlot by the side of the bed that
shit's not that bad no it's good yeah
honestly I'm not a wine connoisseur or
anything like that but it's just kind of
like I can't tell the difference between
a [__] 11 bottle of wine and a
[__] 50 bottle of wine so I got I
already discussed all this
good wine is good wine and people
long as you like it it's good I kind of
feel like people have under like
understand that now that you can
actually get a really decent bottle of
wine for like 10 bucks yeah you know
what I mean yeah I mean some bottles of
one that were 10 bucks are terrible but
you can get good ones for that and
there's really nice better be goddamn
good yeah
it was only back in the old days that
you that bad wine existed all white is
pretty good now yeah you can't really
get away with like super shitty stuff
the way it used to be able to and what I
said earlier I said you could take that
box of [__]
Walmart Merlot wine
and jump in a time machine
and go back into the 1700s or the 1600s
and give that wine to a King and he
would say this is the best wine I've
ever had because it would be yeah
compared to the [__]
but they didn't know any better
everything sucked yeah so everything
just tasted like ass a lot of [__] that
came out of the those wine bottles back
then was [__] sour and [__] nasty
because the bottles weren't clean like I
said they didn't know anybody you know
the real good quality wine and maybe
they washed the bottles most of them
tasted pretty good and they all kind of
tasted similar it may not taste exactly
the same but they all tasted similar
nowadays they can take they all taste
exactly the same
and none of them go spoiled I mean
they're all Pleasant to taste I was just
thinking you could take like some
[__] sandwiches from Circle K back to
the past and they probably think that
was really delicious [__] ever yeah they
are I mean you could take a [__]
Circle K microwave burrito
take that [__] back to [__] medieval
England okay back in Essex
Worcestershire shakes
yeah some topics
in British neighborhoods and [__] you go
to there and pan them how about Dorking
yeah yeah the the the the Lord of
Dorking
red hot burrito and he'd love that you
know
the idea that it came in a plastic bag
would blow his [__] mind like
foreign
you must be from like a wonderful
utopian age never touched by human hands
which I guess it kind of is yeah I know
people like to piss him out but I'm just
like think about think about all the
miraculous things that we have if you
went back in time and told people about
the [__] they'd be like holy crap like
you guys must live in the [__] Garden
of Eden or something all the cool [__]
you guys have
Allison says I prefer the muscle men and
the twinks to The Fetish stuff
fair enough
Allison said that yeah
Jeffy Hart said there's a low budget she
must have been listening fantasy what
just been listening to me and the
stories about
about Dan
one of the guys I this bodybuilder guy
that I know we were
I would get [__] uh anabolics from
him sometimes and he was he he makes
pork he makes gay porn he's a straight
guy that makes gay airport I said well
that's where the money is yeah and for a
straight guy that's where the money is
[__] huge man huge he looks he
looks good too
and that's what he would do is he'd get
super [__] hot he's super jacked up
on tremblem Trend makes you [__] a
psycho
which if you're new here yeah we have
personal experience with that because
Tom took it for a while and turned into
the goblin the goblin essentially
basically
requesting a goblin and a werewolf yeah
and uh
yeah that's what he does is um
he gets [__] up on Trend he gets
really [__] big
uh takes a whole bunch of Viagra and and
sometimes we use something called try
mix which that's a it's an injectable
serum you inject into your dick and
you'll just you'll be hard for like 24
hours
and there's all kinds of things you got
to have on hand some antidotes if
anything goes wrong you gotta know how
to [__] make a certain incision to
drain blood out of you if it goes wrong
there's all kinds of weird [__] that
could go wrong with trimex and basically
what he does is
um
twinks
pay him
basically basically the
I don't want to say the r word but to be
very rough on these dudes yeah and it's
kind of like a r fantasy
these twigs and this muscle man not like
we haven't said that word on like all of
our trip I know a lot of people will
bleep it out because they're sensual but
it doesn't look consensual yeah like
it's a fantasy yeah sure but you know
that's part of the reason the paperwork
all sorts it out the guys signed the
consent form and everything after the
fact and he's well that's why they have
to do that because no it's consensual
because if they have these fantasy
situations where it looks like somebody
is like not willing yeah they have to
know that their ass is covered on that
[__] which like I said it's a pain in
the ass like for us as performers like
to have to go through all this kind of
crap but you understand like why they do
it yeah and part of the [__] thing is
after the whole thing's done
Dan will [__] grab the money and
because look at this look at this six
hundred dollars he paid me six hundred
dollars for what I did there just a
weird [__] you know just rubbing it in
his face you know I kind of want to
watch it I kind of want to watch it yeah
I've never seen it he just told me he's
just watch it I wouldn't watch that [__]
you win it he wanted me to work with him
I'm going no I don't know man you'll
have a good time man we'll make so much
money I love it I love gay porn
I love games
so now I can't have videos of me like
that out there man I can't do that [__]
you're the cutest twink ever man you'll
love him and I'm like no no man no man
does that meanwhile I'm over here going
to do it
[Laughter]
look and I was so
your girlfriend to think about
somebody said same thing see so she
loves it
women are free we're free we're freaky
[__] we're freaks and we don't even and
we don't even like say out loud like 90
of the [__] we think so
just I've got a picture I got a picture
think of that I got a picture I'm like a
show
okay I'll go get it I'll go get it I
think it's just another tablet Camp guy
says just buy cheap vodka and mix it
with good fruit juice that's what we do
I mean honestly we just usually buy a
fifth like every week we usually buy
like a fifth of I usually get sky but
sometimes if I'm a little bit broke I'll
get Pinnacle because it's like half the
price and then we just either Tom will
make lemonade or you know some kind of
berry kind of juice or something like
that
and uh we'll just mix it with that or
sometimes we'll just get um
I don't know just like orange juice or
Minute Maid kind of fruit punch or
something like that it mix it with that
before I get that picture I just wanted
to [__]
that's my screen saver
my screensaver is I can't see that
my screen saver is Gen in porn mode
I can't see it so I can you don't need
to see it well I know but I know but I
don't remember what it looks like this
one
oh okay
John Smith said you could take a fork
back to Medieval England and people
would think you were pretty fancy and
French yeah yeah they didn't have Forks
back then they just picked [__] up with
their hands and stuffed it in their bag
not really
but probably kinda I saw something else
that I wanted uh Victor says gay porn
made me gay yeah
Zach says
[Laughter]
I love it Allison said twinks are
adorable they are
and then she said I love the Asian ones
I thought I had a picture of Dan
Dan with his shirt off
I was real into like all those um do you
remember all those all those boys that
they had in propaganda like that guy
yeah that was mine that was my jam yeah
they're kind of like twinks a little bit
they're just like real real skinny goth
boys
like that were kind of
feminine a little bit but Tanya was
riding one of them
you know Dave koviak
yeah that he was the hottest one yeah he
was so hot that he was kind of famous
and he wasn't even like a musician or
anything I don't think he was just
famous for being in those hot pictures
that's Dan
just trying to get this [__] to [__]
Focus I can't what is wrong I can't even
tell what that is
it's an upshot oh damn okay
of man boobs
okay
yeah that's him
he looks like who's that wrestler that
has that has a hat like that
but I just remember there was a wrestler
that had not Ric Flair he had the
that blonde
mullet
you get a mullets man we were at [__]
remember we were at Barbarella last
Saturday and Saturday at Barbarella if
you didn't know it was 80s night and
they were playing a lot of Duran Duran
and they played like wild boys like
early on in the evening and that was
pretty cool but he says that the videos
going on the thing and uh
times like [__] I forgot like Simon
LeBron having to [__] mullet back
then yeah although I will argue that in
the wild boys video which came out in
1985. Simon's hair was not really a
mullet John Taylor's hair on the other
hand that was a mullet big time but
mullets back in the 80s were not
rednecky yet I guess no they were still
New Wave they were still kind of New
Wave like it was still kinda John Gore
says sunny day yeah Victor said he was
like Randy Savage that's that's what I
was thinking of thank you yeah he always
knows what I'm thinking of yeah I
couldn't think of his name I just
thought of Ric Flair because Ric Flair
apparently just put out an energy drink
and the energy drink is called woo
that's the name of it Dave Victor would
you let him rough you up
make a whole video with you if you meet
up his if you if you how much how much
does they pay I'm not a boy so I can't
meet up with his to his standards I
don't know I don't know how much he pays
them in the videos they're paying him
but I don't know if that that's probably
not true
nothing nothing in these videos is
real everything's the setup and it's all
part of a mind [__] I did a video that I
had up for sale that where I was
pretending that you because you actually
were out that night you were a bike
night and I said I'm gonna do a video
because we've been talking about it
earlier you're cheating on me where I
was like talking to somebody that I've
been like cheating on him with which
like I said obviously he cheats on me
with you yeah like I said I obviously
didn't really do that but it was just
kind of like I told her to do it yeah
[Laughter]
so I had to like pretend I was talking
to like some random person and I said
I'm gonna do a so
I wanted it yeah that's on stream made I
think no it's on oh yeah it is it's not
and it's on many boots too I think I
think is it yeah
yeah Tammy says I think Tom should get
pegged
y'all gonna have to [__] put up a
whole bunch of money
someone's gonna do it she was [__] me
the other day you know or I placed that
order so what order for that strap on
I'm just trying to keep you on your toes
I'm just like you know trying to keep
you nervous this is just the universal
fantasy that these [__] degenerate
women have is the try to deflower these
[__] virgin men trying to [__]
it's just the more uncomfortable it
makes you the funnier it is
me
you know what I'm like you're gonna
we're gonna have to [__] do a singing
you go Amazon on me
yeah yeah that's where you [__] grab
me by the ankles and [__] twist them
behind my head and [__] get up on top
of my dick and just ride the [__] out of
it okay yeah that's the Amazon position
yeah yeah
the dominant female that's fun actually
that's not Pig
putting the women in the dominant
position yeah yeah I like that yeah you
do reverse Amazon flip around backwards
I got the camera and everything
yeah we'll have to do what we want to do
one like that just flexible you grab my
leg put her legs behind her head [__]
well I used to do when I was a kid I
used to do ballet and yeah uh
yeah I had a whole I had a whole like
fourth in class I did 50 years old so
you can still Bend her up into a
pretzels
yeah I can but I can actually put my
feet back and like hook my feet into the
headboard is the headboard yeah got her
feet hung up in the head
don't talk to [__] to her
yeah I used to be I haven't done it in a
while but I used to be able to do splits
and back bends and all that kind of
stuff I could probably still do it if I
if I limbered up first well deca
is real good for George I showed you the
[__]
I showed you the uh the medical
details on that it's real good to
rebuild joints [__] pain relief for
joints tendons it's good for all that
let's see
uh uh
Zach says I really like
lean Nordic dudes
and you all know my major favorite I'm
also crushing major heart of my
Norwegian buddy Henrik even though he
has a girlfriend and two kids well
what are you gonna do
Victor says I like 20 year old skinny
Mexican dudes that drive Mustangs or
trucks
haha
see everybody's got their own thing
everybody's got their own thing Tammy's
wanting to pop up on her stream mate no
come come join us up on stream bait that
would be awesome go go exclusive and
turn the camera on we'll have a
threesome we can't stream it as often as
we would like to because you know
because I'm still working
full-time and so like usually by the
time I get home I'm like oh God I'm too
tired you know what I mean but so
sometimes we'll do it on weekends like
this past week we actually did on Monday
morning because I was off on Monday and
that was really that was really busy
you just got to get back into the
independent mindset like you used to
have yeah well I mean it's it's yeah
it's it's comforting to to know that you
have a certain amount of money coming
every week
but we can beat that
that's what I mean like the more after I
figured out mathematically that really
technically you would only need
48 paid minutes a day
um to match what I was making yeah and
we were getting 15 minutes an hour and
the thing about it is that my job is far
away like it's a long commute I spend
300 a month in gas
just going back and forth there bill
says the way it goes though is that you
make
70 or 60 or 70 one day the next day you
make 300 and then finally goes back and
then like you might go a day with you
know only making 80 or 9 and then the
next day you make 150 you know there is
an average to it but it just says just
for no reason at all
you'll have these windfalls where you'll
make like three or four hundred in a day
I think he said the biggest they ever
made I think he said was 900 in a day
see that like that kind of stuff made me
feel better and like and that day like
Monday when we were on in the morning
and we were only on for like an hour and
15 minutes and we like immediately like
made 45 or something like that and I was
just like okay well I feel better now
because yeah and the re and we would
have stayed on longer but we had plans
like we were going out and so like we
couldn't it just what is everything he's
told me so far is it has been proven to
be accurate he says just
the key is treating it like a job and
just getting hours in just getting yeah
and he says it has to be 30-ish hours a
week that's it which is 30-ish yeah like
I said I work 40 hours a week at my job
plus another 10 hours in commute time
because it's an hour each way and that's
two hours a day so it's better we're
being our own bosses we'll work two on
two off one on one off you know what I
mean I'm much better at like running my
own [__] yeah depending on how the flow
of traffic is going
well I told you it's like I'm pretty
sure I mean unless something crazy
happens
I think I'm gonna put my notice in at
the end of next week and work out the
rest of the month and then yeah
yeah
how much I bet they won't want you to go
well I don't it doesn't matter yeah it
does it so what if they can't tie me to
the [__] chair well I mean I guess
they could but maybe they'll give you
maybe I'll
give you the uh
uh contract employment I mean what else
doesn't really matter at this point like
I said I still have a bunch of freelance
clients that I do so you're right and we
still do the show and everything we just
focus on stream bait we'd make money
yeah
Tammy said I'll have to start saving up
my money for a private pegging show
I mean if you just if you paid
would probably feel better because then
he would like feel like that nobody else
is cute
although if we got that I would record
that because
these girls are fantasizing
to get me to do some [__] like that
we're going to talk about motorcycle
yeah if somebody might stop a motorcycle
like he'll think about it and I'll start
thinking about it you start talking
about something like a motorcycle just
but no
oh Zach is talking about I have a whole
support team and [__] [__] get me
ready and everything you know like I'm
getting Zach and get Zach and all his
gay friends to come over here and
[__] print me up
you know keep rubbing his toes okay it's
okay it's okay this is the first time
for everything I'll catch it they give
me the Virgin talks and [__] hahaha
it would be funny I [__] videotape
the whole thing make a [__]
pay-per-view or something Adam
said don't worry Jenny I will record it
also
I'm just very excited about this
I know or we're the worst well the funny
thing about it was that we were in the
room the other day
and somebody came in and just said
pegging and I was like this must be
somebody from the show or maybe not
maybe it was just like some random we
busted up laughing as soon as the dude
said yeah because I was like are you
from our other show
because I just thought that was funny
they just walked in and said that yeah
it was yes it was Victor yes probably
yeah Zach's talking about how um also
had a crush on Morton harkett from aha
yeah he's pretty hot back in the day he
wasn't my main dude like I said I was
real into
um
Simon lamon from Duran Duran and um
Martin Gore from Depeche Mode and who
else
his name
[__] I just had it I just had it
um I also really liked Richard Butler
from psychedelic first
he's gay too but I didn't know that at
the time
I don't know why personally feel any for
a bathroom break here
sorry we always this show I don't know
man we always end up talking about one
of three topics or all three topics it's
usually like food cats or porn that's
pretty much what we end up doing and
we've been talking about porn a lot more
lately since we've started doing
streaming like a while back so we always
have like funny stories about that but
that's just what happens we're just like
talking about our life and that's what
our life is now so it's just
it's just that's okay got a new um
got a new uh Sheehan shipment in today
also
got like some I'm just gonna say like
some regular clothes but you know some
cool tops and stuff like that also got
some what top what Tom now calls work
clothes which are just kind of like
[__]
like net kind of body stockings and [__]
like that that I can wear on the show
because you have to we're we're still
trying to like refine what the best
outfits are for the show like for
easily easy access you know what I mean
because you're just kind of like well
you have to be able to pop your tits out
you have to but you have to like be able
to sit in it comfortably without anybody
seeing anything because like I said
you can't you're technically not
supposed to show anything like in public
you can show your you can show your
boobs you can do that but you can't um
you're not supposed to show anything but
people do though I don't think they'll
do anything to you if nobody reports it
and I don't think people are reporting
it because they're like hey we're
getting a free show like why would
anyone complain but
I don't know but I'm just thinking well
like I said I'm on here to make money so
I'm not giving away like free [__] you
know what I mean like if you like if
somebody gives me a tip because you can
do that too like you can send like five
bucks or something like that I was like
yeah I'll flash my tits at you for you
know 30 seconds or whatever but
I am totally out of cologne
oh [__] we meant to go to the um we
meant to go to CBS I got some more
because I needed some more too yeah
we could stop there on the way I think
now CVS probably closed by nine one
I think they close at 10 but I'm not
real sure it's on the way
it is but like I said I'm not sure what
time it closes around here I'm imagining
10 but I'm it could be nine I don't know
it's almost nine now
I know you're fine we're fine
um I was just laughing because Allison
said be right back she was gonna she
needed a bathroom break because of all
the [__] we're talking about
um
let's see uh and Zach is still crushing
on Robin Gibb because he's on this whole
BG's thing yeah his sad eyebrows and
long hair oh
John Gore said the second look first
never got enough credit they were really
good yeah I still listen to them all the
time they were really one of the first
bands I really really got into they were
good but they kind of went a little too
pop that I remember well in the late 80s
they kind of started to go a little bit
more mainstream I mean honestly I was
really into I had their first
three albums
I think
I had talk talk and forever now yeah
were my favorite ones yeah forever now
they had president gas on it yeah yeah
that's a great [__] song yeah we saw
them live actually I've seen them live
several times probably three or four
times but we saw them live together I
saw them at a hotel at um it was at Hard
Rock Live Hard Rock Hotel yeah yeah yeah
we saw them there and they were really
good the the cool thing about them and
every time I've seen them because like I
said I've seen them three times maybe
four times
um every single time I've seen them they
always look like they're having the best
[__] time they just always look like
they're really enjoying themselves yeah
I don't know what that dude's on I don't
know what Butler's on but he's all over
the [__]
[__]
I mean he dances about like Mick Jagger
it's like watching Mick Jagger he does
yeah he's just all over the [__]
place
but they always just look like they're
having a really they always seem really
happy like they're just like having
having a [__] blast you know what I
mean
it's like it's pretty awesome
Paul Floyd says the first time here I'm
traumatized LOL
[Laughter]
that like senior name in the chat before
like I just I'm sure you probably like
listened to the show before but this
might be the first time you've been in
the chat so
because I told him I said inevitably our
side track shows and actually our
regular shows too even though we try not
to but we usually end up talking about
either food or cats or porn yeah so
I mean it's kind of hard to give a date
advice though kind of our oh and dating
advice yeah we do that yeah we do that
too trying to whip these young guys in
shape
they suck now they suck well but I
understand it's not everywhere here in
Florida
people are normal
you know they're kind of like they
always were
I mean you still see dudes
I see High School dudes come in to
Starbucks all the time with hot
girlfriends they're all in high school
and dudes are [__] they're ripped you
know physical looking and real
attractive teenage girls from high
school and stuff that are into sports
and everything so they they have all
that still you know
um which that's traditional
American
Lifestyles a habit but they have
everything else too
but it's just um
it's they're calling what's happening
mostly they really say it's bad in the
UK they call it the crisis of
masculinity
that the that the young men of today
gen Z mostly they don't have a role in
life
well [__]
we were all kind of like that when
you're in your [__] teens and 20s you
don't really have a role yet you're too
young but they say a lot of these guys
you know they're overweight
um or just totally demoralized
uh never had a girlfriend
um just
play video games that's it and just
retreating they're becoming Japanese
otaku basically
don't want girlfriends don't want a car
you know that's just unheardable those
[__] need to snap out of that you
have to get competent real quick
or you'll die
you know one way or the other you'll die
you'll kill yourself
drink yourself to death
um get involved in something too early
and you don't have the strength to fight
it and it kills you
there's all kinds of [__] that could
happen to you it's always better to be
strong than to be weak it's just this is
the law of nature
and men are already disposable
it doesn't matter if you die really as a
man well everyone's kind of yeah
everyone is even more so disposable well
yeah they die and it doesn't matter
they're just replaced with another one
well they they're not the ones like
birthing children yeah they're just not
as important really to the to the
species they were always more expendable
and there was always hypergamy it was
always the top 20 30 of the guys getting
all the women
but that's in the breeding population
not in the non you know if you get too
old you're just not doing it's just not
in you but when it comes to the young
people yeah it was always the top 20.
top 20 20 top 30.
it's just that dating apps and social
medias have magnified the problem
and then these dudes are getting beaten
down
because they believe what women say
all right which I've gotten into that
don't ever believe what a woman says
when she comes at you with well you got
to be six feet tall at least and at
least make six figures and at least have
a six-pack to 666
no
you that same girl that said that you
see her two months later and she's with
a five foot seven dude who's chubby and
who [__] works at Walmart and she's
loving him
okay don't believe what women say
they're just throwing things out there
well and sometimes too let me let me
stomp you right there because sometimes
too women will tell you that because
they don't want to go out with you
specifically for whatever reason but
they don't really want to tell you that
to your face because it would be mean so
they always come up with some other kind
of reason because they're trying to like
Let You Down Easy yeah and women do not
make sense so yeah we do no they don't
yeah we do no not from the man's point
of view I'll tell you something that
this is true I'm not gonna name any Nays
but a woman told me this
that she used to do this
if a guy if if there was a guy she
really liked
and he approached her she would shut him
down and raise her standards and make it
tougher for him so he so he would have
to prove his love for her
basically well she wanted to see if he
was interested enough right yes now
that same girl
would be in a club the week before and
see a dude who's eh I don't really want
to go out with this dude
Obama [__] this dude just tonight
and then she goes and [__] that dude so
she lowered her standards for that guy
that she didn't like but raised her
standards for the guys that she did like
so now he's going out with her oh I got
her man I had to go through jumping on
all this she had to jump through all
these hook Hoops boy she's real
prestigious and he says that to his
buddy goes oh who her oh I [__] her
last week
you know what I mean he's a slob you
know and he's not lying and he's like
what and then that guy feels like he's
been hoodweight you know and you're like
yeah but raise the standards but Deeds
do that to women all the time yeah guys
are about the same if she's hot he's up
for it guys would demand very little
standards on men are low
we were designed to have low standards
that's why all this damn hoflation is
happening these guys they're he's a
seven and he's going out with a four
because she says she's a 10. it's called
hoflation these women have inflated
Their Own no no
guys don't do that guys will basically
go out with whoever they think is hot
and they don't care if they have money
or not or they're not really gold
diggers it's just they like her and is
she hot that's or if she is she hot
enough you know what I mean
it shouldn't have to be
an eight or a nine she just has to be
hot enough for him
Paul Flynn says nothing better than tits
as my grandma used to say then she got
them out
[Laughter]
see my grandma's tits and my nightmares
it's called the joke Tom yeah
um Zach says oh looks like ariaster and
Joaquin Phoenix were just spotted
scouting locations for their new movie
in New Mexico
that's awesome isn't ariaster doing the
Nosferatu remake or am I remembering
that wrong actually tomorrow I think
we're gonna go see last Voyage of the
Demeter so I'm like very excited about
that Tammy said Tom isn't even drunk
enough for wigs yet that's when the
shows get good no waves today I'm
serious well because we have to go soon
so he can't get like super super drunk
yeah uh Paul Flynn said my standards are
too high yeah
uh Allison had to go hopefully she's not
gone already but um yeah she said I'm on
my way out have fun I'll be back for
another stream by Tom and Jenny Bye
Allison hopefully you had a good time
but yeah we're we're playing to we're
playing to Paul Flint because this is
his first time in the Stream so he's
like a stream virgin
[Laughter]
so it's like he shouldn't be surprised
at any of the other kinds
uh John Gore said I've seen some damn
good looking guys no homo
yeah yeah hopefullflation
well like I said you see some kind of
like
I don't know you see some kind of like
hot chicks with some
not so good looking deals yeah those
dudes always have something up their
sleeve money uh status uh sense of humor
it's a bunch of [__] happening this is
the thing okay hold on stop oh I don't
talk to these men here
because I'll forget I'll forget I'll
forget
Tom's got a rant yeah
women will will tell you
they you know forget I forgot where I
was going with this [__]
she's laughing
where was it
[Laughter]
Zach says the Nosferatu remake
is the guy who did the witch
Ari's new movie is apparently a dark
comedy Noir set in a mining town during
the pandemic
I'm trying to remember what I what I was
talking about
huh
oh I'm waiting for you to come back
why I see you can rant and I forgot what
I was talking about oh okay
I didn't keep talking I laughed yeah you
kept making fun of me and then yeah I
forgot oh okay I'm sure it wasn't
anything all that important no it was it
was no it wasn't it's part of this don't
tell me
that's what you tell me every time you
interrupt me and I forgot what I was
saying you're like I wasn't that
important anyway like yeah it probably
wasn't that important
um oh nasrachi remake is the guy did the
wish that's right Robert Eggers
that's right I was for some reason I
always get the two of them confused I
don't know why uh is the is the new film
show them to the corn good what did they
what they made a new children for the
corn no they need to get rid of all the
children only the first one was any good
I mean the first one is kind of like so
bad it's good yeah it was it was not
that good it's super Jersey yeah and I
think I can't even believe that spawned
a franchise honestly and I I'm gonna say
that I think
because I really like the short story
that it's based on but the movie they
changed a lot
and I kind of think that if they were
gonna remake it they should make it
closer to the short story I don't know
what the [__] they did in the sequels
because
I can't imagine I mean I guess there's
some lore there that you can explore
like the whole you know He Who Walks
Behind The Rose kind of
all the all the mythology behind that
like maybe they explored that more but
it's like I was just kind of like I
still do like the first one from 1984
just because of nostalgia
it's kind of terrible though it's bad
it's a well it's not the worst Demon
King adaptation but it's better it's
better than [__] raw head Rex
well that was Clyde Barker
it's better than anything it's better
than that movie it's better than I put
it up talking about Stephen King
adaptations it's better than
Sleepwalkers it's better than the
langoneers it's better than dream
catcher
so I put I put it's better than The
Shining TV series I like the Chinese I
know you did but I did not like it I
liked it it was closer to the book
that's why I didn't like it that good it
was it wasn't I don't like it although I
you know I bet you could you could
remaster that and release it it'll
probably look a lot better
I don't know that's the way the book was
I know but
like I said and I've talked about this
before
the thing that Kubrick understood about
making the shining the definitive movie
in 1980 and why that's still a classic
and why people are still talking about
it is because that he knew that a book
and a movie are two different things and
sometimes you have to change [__] up
it's the same story pretty much though
yeah he didn't change that much he just
did it from what what Wendy would have
seen he he cut out all the exposition
yeah in a book you can get away with
Exposition in a movie not so much all
the expositions gone all the other
viewpoints like you don't you don't see
what Jack's Viewpoint was yeah you don't
see what the what the what the what the
ghosts what their viewpoints were yeah
of what was going and that's just windy
when they did the what would the
haunting what would that event what
would it what would it what would it
have looked like [__] man I can't talk
what would it have looked like if you
were um just Wendy
and that's the story you got when in in
the Kubrick film
yeah just Wendy's point of view well
like I said it worked a lot better
because you were in the same position as
they were you were seeing things as you
would see it if you were staying in that
hotel and you didn't know what the [__]
was going on you didn't even know about
the ghost right she didn't know about
all this [__] it wasn't until the end
that she started seeing it and I liked
that the ghosts in Stanley Kubrick's
version just looked like people
whereas like in the TV series the one
that Stephen King uh wrote like he he
did the teleplay and I think mcgarris
directed it
um but that one like the ghost looked
like ghost they had like monster makeup
on and [__] like that and I'm just like
that's just dumb it just looks dumb they
overdid it it's much scarier when it's I
mean Lloyd
that's [__] scary he just looked like
a dude he didn't look like a ghost he
didn't have monster makeup on he just
looked like a dude but you knew that
there was something off about it you
know what I mean
um let's see Tammy says uh movie on
Amazon Prime chained starring uh Vincent
d'onofario as a serial killer oh I think
I saw that uh he said a slow burn but
the end is worth the wait I'm pretty
sure that I've seen that but I'm gonna
have to re-watch it like to see if I
remember Paul Flint said I like Needful
Things
I did you know what we did a review of
that not too long ago because I hadn't
seen it in such a long time I read the
book a long time ago too
and I actually that it's not a great
movie but it is like a pretty
entertaining adaptation I'm I have like
a weird fascination with like Stephen
King adaptations
like a really weird Fascination and
somebody mentioned like Storm of the
Century and I just rewatched that like
recently too and I did like a big I did
a video for it on over on my other
channel and like wrote a big long thing
about it I actually ended up liking that
a lot more than I thought I would I
would like to eventually go back and
re-watch Rose Red because I remember
really liking that like because I it was
kind of like his take on Haunting of
Hill House the Shirley Jackson novel
but and I remember it being really good
but I haven't seen it since it
originally aired on TV which when the
[__] was that 2002 something like that I
remember it was when I lived in Tampa
and that was in the early 2000s that's
when I saw it
I'd almost start considering um shut
down well we will in a little bit like I
said we don't actually have to leave
until 9 30 so we're fine yeah but I
didn't you want to go to store
yeah but we got a few more minutes just
let me just chill out and let me
let me uh drink
Paul Flynn said I really liked uh
Nosferatu I started watching that I
still haven't read the book
yeah and I know that's not Stephen King
that's Joe Hill but um and I really
liked it but if for some reason I didn't
finish it so I'll get around to it but I
did um
I did read some of Joe Hill's other
stuff I read horns that was really good
and the movie was actually pretty good
too with Daniel Radcliffe and um
Heart-Shaped Box was also good
which I think Oracle left
but I think it was Oracle that
recommended
the T Kingfisher novel a house with good
bones and I wanted to tell her that I
had bought it like I bought it last week
and I started reading it today and it's
so far it's like really really good I'm
gonna review it but it probably won't be
till next week because because I
actually ended up reading another novel
this past week
um
the last house on needless street so I
might do a review of that but I have
like another movie review to do first
there's like some other videos I have to
do first
um John Gore said Needful Things reboot
would have to work eBay and Etsy into it
unless you said it back
I kind of feel like a lot of horror
movies now are just gonna like [__] it
we're just gonna set it in the 80s or
the 90s like this makes this [__] a lot
easier
like for the past couple of days
I've been listening to somebody but I
can't remember the name of the channel
but somebody made like a three three and
a half hour documentary
it's on YouTube about analog horror
and it's really good like it's really
comprehensive like I didn't know like a
huge amount about it but I am kind of
like a fan of that sub genre
so I've been listening to it and
um
he was actually and that kind of
reminded me that a lot of horror
nowadays
so much of it is like set back in the
80s and 90s and I think some of that is
just because of the proliferation of
analog horror how many people are like
um like even people that weren't born at
the time but are really like nostalgic
for 70s 80s like or like old media that
they did an experience
firsthand
so I think it's that but I also think
like as a horror writer it's much easier
to write something that was set before
cell phones and the internet because
it makes [__] a lot more mysterious and
it makes [__] a lot
more difficult because you can't just
you know it's a lot scarier if you're in
a horror movie where it's like oh my God
I'm like my car broke down in the middle
of nowhere it's like now you're just
like oh I have a cell phone I'll just
like [__] call Triple A and I'm fine
you know back in the old days you
couldn't do that you were kind of [__]
so I think that's kind of why a lot of
ones are set back then too in the past
people have asked you about video games
I bought a new video game the other day
that I could recommend so far
I think it's Japanese game based on
the gameplay so far and certain things
that I've seen I think I think it's made
in Japan it's called stray I got it off
the Xbox Xbox one you can download it
and in in this game stray you play as a
cat
that's pretty good you're a cat in a
post-apocalyptic world
and you get separated from your friends
your other cat friends you fall down a
hole and you end up in a
in a basically like a subterranean
underground city and it's abandoned
and then uh you got to figure out how to
get out of this city and get back to
your other cats
and uh so far I found out that all the
people are dead
but there's robots in there AI robots
that they're alive
and they're they've kind of Taken
people's Place places they they're silly
though but it's fun it's a fun game so
it's called straight it looks cool yeah
the graphics are real good yeah Paul
says stray is Ace yeah he's played it
yeah yeah I had heard of it before and
I'm not like a huge video game
connoisseur the fact that I had heard of
it means it must have proliferated like
it's a puzzle game running jumping
trying to figure out puzzles and stuff
not really puzzles but just trying to
solve things
and uh it's got good graphics and I like
the tone of the games kind of relaxing
but it's still kind of there's an
adventure to it it's kind of chills you
out
see that's the thing I think if I had
time to play video games which I don't
but
I think I would prefer more stuff that
was like chill like that yeah because
the music well stuff that has just like
Monsters running at your face like I'm
stressed out enough as it is I don't
need like stress added on to it like
that would probably just give me anxiety
hey they're also offering for 10 bucks
the remastered Quake 2 from the 90s I'm
gonna go back and get that too
have played quake in a long time
yeah because you have that got all the
Dooms yeah well and you have that
package too that has like all those old
arcade games yeah right yeah I got the
Williams arcade I got I got all kinds of
stuff I got all the Sega Genesis games
those aren't even really fun to play
anymore though I used to like Sonic the
Hedgehog Sonic's the best ones yeah I
used to play that but mostly like I said
the last time I was super into video
games was like when we had
when we had Legend of Zelda and Metroid
yeah and that was like old Nintendo old
school [__] because
Mega Man because I'm old they got a
million Mega Man platform games and like
you know Tetris and [__]
I was like
uh Paul says I love Mafia games they're
great
yeah I was like somebody's talked about
the movie hero also I kind of remember
that one with Dustin Hoffman holy crap
yeah she's going to bathroom did you
guys hear that she's in the um that's
the new kitty yeah Dakota and she's in
the litter box and she just like makes
as much noise as possible yeah
I have the kind of litter box we have a
litter box for Pokey
also but this one has like
um big what do you call it like big
pellets in it because I was trying that
out and she seems to like that Pookie
didn't like it she was just kind of like
what is this I can't poop in this so she
wouldn't use it so we have another one
that's more regular litter but I do
still have the the pellet one and um
Dakota seems to like that one though but
man she gets in there and she's just
she just makes all kind of noise but I
was just kind of like all right but she
seems to enjoy it so
you know
uh let's see
John Gore said just saw a barbarian
Sound Studio it was okay a bit much on
the artistic Flair it should have been
more smoking in it though considering
Italian movie studio in the 70s yeah
yeah I actually really like that movie I
kind of like
I like all those kind of like giallo
homages and like giallo adjacent kind of
movies like Barbarian Sound Studio it
wasn't exactly a giallo movie like not
in the way that it was plotted or
anything but the way that it like the
look of it was kind of like a and it was
about a giallo movie so it was kind of
like about like he was doing the sound
for it but I don't know I really liked
it but I think like the more recent ones
that I've seen that were more
giallo-esque
that I was really into were
um Francesca which I think came out in
2015 and that was like very much like an
old Jello movie like from the 1970s they
tried like deliberately to make it look
like that
um there was also one called
that I think came out in 2017 maybe that
it was called The Strange color of your
body's tears and that one wasn't trying
to look like an old Jello film but it
was very much like a modern updated
yellow film but that thing was like
inscrutable I thought it was cool though
like visually it was really cool but I
had no [__] idea it was going on most
of the time put my other shirt on yeah I
see it oh it's shiny
also if you haven't seen it I don't know
and I hesitate to recommend things to
people because I don't want people to
get mad at me and it's like I don't
really know
people's very specific taste because I
have like really weird like
idiosyncratic uh tastes in horror movies
but one movie that I saw quite recently
that I really really dug was in Fabric
and it's kind of like I wouldn't call it
a Jello movie it's not but it's um it
has some giallo
like Tendencies to it but it's more like
surrealist
it's a you can say like this sounds
dismissive but it's like essentially
about a haunted dress or like a cursed
dress
but not exactly
it's pretty it's weird but I was like I
was really into it I thought it was
really really cool it was I think it was
British
um
John Gore said I like the one Foley
artist who doesn't say anything but is a
dead ringer for poultry holy [__] like
on shutter there is a documentary about
Lucio fulchi called faulty for fake
which I still haven't watched yet even
though it has like five skulls which is
like the big thing oh I should mention
too and we haven't even done a review of
this yet I think somebody recommended a
long time ago that Tom watch the movie
what is it called bloody muscle
bodybuilder yeah yeah yeah and that was
on shutter yeah I loved it and we
watched it the other day yeah it's
Japanese and it's from the 90s and it's
like really super super low budget it's
like it looks like it's like even it's
like 4-3 aspect ratio and you can tell
that they were trying to make an evil
dead I think it's even called the
Japanese Evil Dead yeah bloody muscle
bodybuilder from hell in Hell In inhale
inhale yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's the
Japanese Evil Dead essentially I mean
it's pretty much ripping up but but it
knows that it's ripping it off yeah it's
homage in it and [__] I mean he
basically like looks at the camera as
like groovy you know what I mean like
yeah so they're doing it but it's okay
it's fine I'll allow it it was actually
really fun it started out kind of slow
it's only like an hour long but it
started out kind of slow but then
it got crazier and crazier like toward
the end and honestly like as cheap as
that movie looked it looked like it cost
about a buck 98 but the gore effects
were actually quite good and it had some
stop-motion animation just like the Evil
Dead did which I thought was kind of
neat it's just a well-crafted cheap
movie it's what you expect when you see
we had a good time with it we had a good
time with it yeah yeah but I think yeah
I don't think we ever did a review on it
but we did watch it the other night and
I had a good time with it all right look
I think we should go
yeah okay I guess we better go um oh
wait Lara says what is the real story
behind giallo and J B whiskey was a
product placement or something else I
always kind of wondered about that too
because it's it's kind of like a troop
you always see a bottle of J and B
whiskey I don't know if it was just
because that was a brand that was
popular at the time or they just liked
that the label was yellow and it was
like
went with the color scheme I don't
really know or if it was just around but
it does seem like it was a thing doesn't
it
all right so I guess we better go
because we gotta go out this evening so
you know sorry we had to cut it a little
bit short normally if we were staying
home we'd just go on for four or five
hours just like sit here and get like
super plastered but yeah we can't do
that tonight because we're going out uh
so yeah so we will be back on Monday
hopefully we will be talking about
um on Monday night's stream the last
Voyage of the demeanor because I think
we're going to go see it tomorrow and
I'm really looking forward to it I
haven't read any reviews but it looks
like everybody's kind of like pretty
happy about it so I'm hoping It'll like
the trailer looked kick ass so I'm
excited about seeing it so I think we're
gonna go see it tomorrow so we'll talk
about that on Monday
so as always thank you guys for hanging
out with us on this Friday evening and
we'll see you guys again on Monday night